I'm talking with Gunnar hot mark who's
just given the keynote on the opening
morning of the ftth Council 10th
anniversary event in London go to what
were the some of the main point you were
making to the audience this morning i
would say that we shall rather think
gigabytes than megabytes we need to
think big if we are to be in the lead in
the world i do you think we can do that
can we achieve that yes a gnome 10
pounds and our choices we have the
choice and if we make the right choices
we will do it and if not we will be
number four your form and I myself I
prepared that we shall be the number one
absolutely and are you confident that we
will do you feel there's a will to
achieve it I think that is a will but
I'm not confident in that sense that I'm
sure but I'm confident that we can make
a right choices we have opportunities
governments have opportunities we have
it in European level but we need to make
the right choices that's simple it is
and and you know what's holding us back
do you think is it just simply you know
delays it in realizing the importance of
ftth I think it's a lack of
understanding that the demand will be
increasing and increasing that the main
part of the main growth of our economy
will one way or the other be dependent
on the ICT and the broadband speeds and
capacities I think there is a lack of
understanding that what we see today
already that most new services are one
of the way
other apps in our smartphones and they
are not apps in the phone their
corresponding to services and the
commercial activities in our real
economy yes because we've got apps today
but there's just countless new ones yet
yet to be unveiled at but the network is
so critical isn't it behind all that you
need the network having the capacity
into speed and the need for capacity and
speed is increasing and increasing
increasing that it hand down so the last
10 years and it will do so even more the
next coming decade well girl let's hope
we manage to achieve it and thanks for
speaking to us thank you very much
you